vote the timeline ahead is extremely
challenging
we still need to put into place the
infrastructure needed to implement and
enforce this new regulation
we must ensure that it becomes a success
on the ground inspiring others to follow
I am counting on you to continue this to
spread the word about the urgent need to
tackle
deforestation and Forest degradation and
I'm very grateful to everyone here who's
contributed and supported the efforts to
stop deforestation
we are working against the clock as it
is and I want to make sure that you know
that your calls for Action were worth it
and that continued support is critical
thank you
see
depositions
Miss Hildegard Bento will be telling us
about the position of the development
committee go ahead
ladies and gentlemen with this
deforestation regulation which also
applies to supply chains we are pioneers
here we can guarantee consumers that
beef the soy the palm oil the cocoa the
coffee whether it's a raw or process it
won't be coming from areas that have
been deforested
so that's a real uh progress
but we're going even further than that
we want to ensure that the places of
origin for these
products also have strong rules and
legislation so we will have that
transparency and traceability built in
and we hope that the commission who have
ranked these countries low medium and
high risk uh won't have created
um too many uh enemies with regards to
the marketing of these products
we also need to look at the
implementation of these products and
have close contact with the affected
countries and the farmers themselves
it is important that we have these uh
types of Supply chains worldwide it is a
a huge amount of work ahead of us I
think it's a bit
um idealistic to think we can do this in
one year but I hope this will be
successful even despite the pandemic
thank you very much
thank you
for the agricultural committee
foreign
regulation is very ambitious indeed and
its objectives are very good I have only
one and a half minutes and therefore I'd
like to focus on only one thing and I'm
afraid I'm a bit negative on this matter
one member stayed in the European Union
has
asked its Ministry of Agriculture and
Forestry to put all
in Investments on hold
yeah that that was aimed at cattle
Farmers all Investments should be put on
hold because article 9 is so unclear in
that one single member state that we
don't know in that member State whether
any Investments or any buildings can be
built on farms in the second in the next
few years this is an unbearable
situation from cattle Farmers
perspective cattle farmers in my country
need clear information and clear rules
so I sincerely hope their commissioner
kiriakiras that you deal with this
matter in the commission as soon as
possible so that we have some clarity
and this applies to other member states
than Finland as well
thank you
Alexander van Hooper who's the next
speaker
president commissioner
first of all I'd like to express my
gratitude to Christoph Hansen our
reporter
who has submitted an excellent
draft piece of legislation which will
give us a better idea of how we can
ensure in the future the products
ranging from beef to Cocoa don't come
from areas which are threatened to fire
station this is a very important
proposal and we have to ensure this be
properly implemented
so it's obviously the implementation
will be in the hands of member states
interpretation in the hands of the
commission we have to ensure that
there's no room for maneuver for those
two parties we have to ensure that we
have very strict
checks and strict sanctions if countries
or businesses don't respect the rules
however this legislation should also
ensure that we can continue to conduct
sustainable international trade
and this draft legislation should not
act as a way of blocking future trade
agreements such as mercosur I our
position is this is an important first
step to more sustainable production but
when it comes to trade agreements their
main purpose is to suit is to drop
import duties on sensitive products such
as beef and this shouldn't be diverted
to acting that way work
thank you the next speaker in our
broadcast you're next
very much president thank you colleagues
whether you're buying something at the
train station eating a piece of
chocolate you can't be a short on where
the products are coming from
and we don't think about those things
when we put them in our shopping basket
when we talk about uh cocoa
Timber coffee often these come from
deforestated
locations with deforestation there's no
legislation to forbid that but now we
have closed that loophole
we have really made a difference to our
carbon footprint heat here in the EU
it will have to be uh very clear if
there's going to be Imports into the EU
that there was no deforestation involved
or exploitation of people otherwise
there'll be no access to the EU markets
so we are changing the economic model
here it's not just good for forestry
it's going to be good for consumers in
Europe as well
at the moment there isn't really Clarity
there's many different types of
sustainable labeling and promises and
there's no real Clarity here without
pressure from Civil Society in the
European Parliament we wouldn't be
having this
um legislation that affects the supply
chains as well so there has been that
will within the EU within this house to
build on that parliamentary legislation
to get to the uh resolution to the
legislation in just three and a half
years
in the negotiations we're able to even
improve the uh commission's proposal Mrs
kiriakiri's explained this situation uh
very uh clearly we have included rubber
for example even though there was a loss
of opposition to this we have uh
strengthened the role in the
International Community we have looked
at issues of land grabbing as well
this fight against deforestation is not
one that is one yet the commission over
the next two years will have to look at
other uh important uh ecosystems such as
those in Brazil we want to ensure that
there is no financing of this type of
deforestation and we here in the
European Parliament will maintain that
uh pressure to ensure that we get there
but first of all thank you very much to
those who have negotiated this to the
commission for this Brave initiative and
to all of the uh colleagues who have
worked at Cross party and cross
committee thank you very much bacon
thank you madam
the next speaker Mr dorvoltz
Ender
my name is
first of all I have to say that I'm I
was not to Shadow this legislation
the shadow actually jumped ship it had
probably better if he had jumped ship
before and then we could have had a
discussion about the file
but first this is of course a very
important legislation and an issue we
will certainly come back to in future
years
second this doesn't mean that the the
first station is something easily done
the first risk we are actually running
is The White Man's Burden risk because
we are again telling formerly colonized
countries what they should do and what
they shouldn't be doing
and that doesn't always lend very
elegantly fourth
in a country where 75 percent of the
land area is defined as Forest almost
any new building
is requesting Forest to be cut
this leads to a situation where a milk
farmer with a new shed will be subject
to the deforestation rules
he can sell the milk
but because his obliged to slaughter the
animals under transport of the caresses
to the incineration will be done on his
own account and this is something
with my colleague already referred to
this is not actually acceptable thank
you
thank you Mars
thank you
please
thank you very much president so it's
time for us to talk about forests again
not just for us in the EU but for us
around the world how we should protect
them from felling from deforestation
these issues seem self-evident and we
shouldn't really have to discuss them in
the first place this legislation is a
piece of legislation that can give us a
really positive outcome within the near
future now in Sweden this is actually a
a topical debate
in Sweden we have a broad majority
behind a policy that actually seeks to
undermine to weaken this legislation and
the very same majority notwithstanding
that is claiming that Sweden has the
forestry industry that is the most
sustainable in the world now if our
forestry industry were the most
sustainable of the world then we
wouldn't need this and indeed if this
legislation constitutes a threat towards
Swedish forestry then that means surely
that the Swedish forestry industry isn't
as resilient as some seem to believe and
very very many people are happy to tell
others that this is the case thank you
thank you foreign
ladies and gentlemen
I think everyone agrees with the fact
that we have to save our forests and
that we have to uh care about our
biodiversity however we cannot act
hastily without a proper analysis of
the results especially Financial impact
of those rules I'm speaking here about
Rubber and products derived from rubber
the cost of administrative burden will
be huge we are also unable to see how
this law will influence our trading
balance with other countries and what is
going to happen in the timber sector
that is why the commission should focus
on the EU keeping its leading position
in terms of Timber and agricultural
products this is extremely important
also when we are introducing new rules
we have to pay particular attention to
our small and medium Enterprises
because it is them that will have to
face new challenges of administrative
burden so let's monitor our Market very
closely in the first years of
implementation of this agreement this
law is far from ideal but it still
merits our yes in the vote thank you
thank you
Mateo adenovo
good evening
thank you president ladies and gentlemen
the idea of this legislation is to move
from a silkier economy and to apply
environmental standards which apply in
Europe to the rest of the world the new
rules would provide for imports to
Europe of a whole series of Commodities
and raw materials including Sawyer Cafe
cocoa palm oil and so on be accompanied
by certificates proving that they did
not contribute to deforestation
all of this is based on a system of
traceability which would be enhanced and
controls will be in the hands of member
states who would be allowed to suspend
the marketing on the EU Market of
products causing deforestation
this initial phase would be followed by
other measures where the view to
providing additional conditions for you
exports to the European market so as to
guarantee food environmental security
and social guarantees
in this way the principle of reciprocity
would enable us to control the rest of
the planet as well as European and
Italian consumers thank you you are the
next one
Duncanville Four Seasons
thank you president commissioner
forests are essential for all life on
Earth however they're under a serious
threat the livestock Industries is one
of the major causes of deforestation
this is why it's so important that this
legislation against deforestation be
adopted so as to ensure that soya and
beef which have led to deforestation
would no longer be imported to the
European Union unfortunately Maize pork
and chicken would still be able to be
imported even if they had to chop down
forests to produce them my party the
animal party would like to ensure that
such exports be banned as quickly as
possible
finally the Mercury agreement this trade
agreement with Latin America
this agreement
would deal an enormous blow to a fight
against deforestation the Netherlands
has already made it clear
that
this deal cannot be finalized as long as
agriculture is part of it I would like
to hear what the commissioner would say
to that thank you
the next speaker
president
thank you president thank you
commissioners
I would like to welcome the agreement
reached by co-producers regarding the
move towards zero deforestation it's
very urgent that we bring to a rapid
holds uncontrolled deforestation
in the last decade alone
more than 100 million hectares of forest
have gone up in smoke the time has now
come for us to say stop
biodiversity preservation of systems and
Native populations must be defended at
any price
this regulation is a big step in the
right direction but more has to be done
when it comes to the effectiveness of
controls this is why our hope is that
when it's next reviewed
the percentages are minimal thresholds
for checks to be carried out by the
national authorities would be increased
there's a high risk that our
consumers will not be able to pick
informed choices
why would we want to undermine the
ambitious objectives of this legislation
by not carrying out unnecessary checks
and inspections thank you merciles
thank you president
commissioner collect colleagues
deforestation is an increasing problem
if we fail to deal with it we will
hardly be able to stop your diversity
loss or climate change
we're making concerted efforts in Europe
in this fight and we cannot afford to
have Goods in our markets contributing
to deforestation where in the EU or
anywhere else
so I hope that this week we will finally
conclude the votes on the regulations
the combat deforestation it should
create real tools to fight against
deforestation Forest degradation and
Forest conversion this also applies to
the countries that are trading partners
where for some particularly vulnerable
however the new requirements must be
easy to implement so it's not to impose
uh additional administrative buttons on
the business
for example the implementation of the
requirements of on geographical
coordinates should be accompanied by the
necessary Technical and financial
supports and clear guidance how to do so
I also hope that the list of goods
requirements requiring rigorous due
diligence will be extended if necessary
once regulation is implemented EU
producers must be guaranteed
competitiveness and consumers must have
the right to know whether the goods they
use do not contribute to deforestation
thank you
donkey females
thank you Sean
president the commissioner um
dear colleagues we're all familiar with
the problem is well known
for far too long now our policy has been
highly hypocritical both our economic
and trade policy at the beginning of
this period of parliament in other words
a few years ago the trade committee here
in the European Parliament
put the mucosaur on hold we said we
won't continue
and we fought hard to ensure that trade
policy and the TSD chapter in the
agreement be made more sustainable
so today is an important day
that is this instrument is an important
part of our approach and we shouldn't
underestimate the importance of this
our trade policy is responsible for more
than 16 percent of world deforestation
so we can't on the one hand call for
strict pro-climate policies here in the
European Union while at the same time
allowing all these products into our
Market which of course such rampant
deforestation
so I think it's important that we
support this
I'm very much an advocate of further
strengthening measures in the future on
individual products but I think this is
an important First Step so as to ensure
that we can make our trade policy more
sustainable so I welcome this with open
arms and I will call on you to support
it as well thank you merci Mercy
the floor is yours
colleagues
I think we can really be proud of the
fact that we are voting this
unprecedented text
it is we as the European Parliament who
have led the initiative on this text
starting two years ago pushing the
commission to act in the member states
to accept this and now tomorrow we have
the possibility to definitively vote on
the first law in the world that will
help end imported deforestation the
second thing we can be proud of is that
we owe this to Europeans or the opinion
polls show that Europeans do not want to
contribute to deforestation but
they don't have the opportunity when
they have a hot chocolate or a coffee in
the morning
to know that they are de facto complicit
in imported deforestation whether it's
the deforestation of the Amazon or in
central Africa
we are going to put an end to this and
we can guarantee that they will no
longer be unknowingly complicit in this
deforestation I think that is a real uh
added value from a European perspective
and we're also pulling everybody up with
us already in the US a debate has begun
to see if the U.S should follow in our
footsteps
we are using the strength of our single
Market the largest market in the world
to be able to set the rules that it will
help improve these standards for
globalization and I think we can all be
very proud of this tax prevention
tomorrow thank you
Madam married to sir
[Music]
the decision we're taking today is
historic a huge step forward for forests
around the world climate biodiversity
but also human rights and we should
recall regulating an economy that's gone
off the rails the law of the economy is
not above the law of nature today the EU
is responsible for 16 of deforestation
through products such as soya or cocoa
and that is why it's our responsibility
to guarantee vis-a-vis our European
citizens guarantee that they don't
actually contribute to deforestation
every time they go shopping thank you to
my colleagues rapporte Shadows thanks to
this ambitious proposal by the
parliament we've been able to move
forward the dialogue was not always
straightforward but we now have
additions rubber for instance and
printed paper we have stronger sanctions
also for companies that are not in
compliance with their obligations but we
need to remain Vigilant it is absolutely
essential for this text to be extended
in order to make sure that that we can
protect fragile ecosystems such as
mangroves also we need to think of Maize
and we need to think of financial actors
who actually contribute to deforestation
so we know that in two years time a
number of forests will have been
deforested irreversibly
do you accept yes
please
thank you so much I have a small
question
small question only my question is that
whether um EU farming organization
accept this regulation you know this you
know this problem that what situation is
between agricultural organization they
accept and don't accept this regulation
integration thank you
foreign well dear colleague it depends
there are agricultural organizations in
Europe and indeed around the world who
deplore the fact that we're adopting
this legislation why do they deplore it
because there are a number of practices
that actually amount to deforestation
destroying ecosystems and yet they are
the lungs of the world they are also the
habitat for a number of populations they
need to be able to live there in order
to produce Farm produce for instance or
indeed other produce but unfortunately
we have the use of pesticides noxious
substances and also of course cattle
farming that is one important issue as
well and the regulation today which we
are adopting addresses that as well and
it's also a matter for us in the EU to
change our practices to reduce our meat
consumption but there are of course a
number of farmers around the world who
are delighted that we should be coming
to the help to protect their ecosystems
watch our next speaker is
that
palm oil soya beef inputs the European
market accounts for 16 of World Trade as
a result we are the second
of block responsible for deforestation
in the world to give you an idea of the
surface of soil that covers France
Germany Belgium and the Netherlands
the regulation on deforestation that
you've put forward is left in the right
direction
unfortunately however it's full of
contradictions and fig leaves which are
designed to hide the back sliding of the
European Commission on the inflated
economy for years now the European Union
has been concluding trade agreements
which with countries around the world
which go against the interests of the
environment for example ongoing
agreement with murka sir which will not
only kill our economy and our Farmers it
would also speed up deforestation in
South America in the face of this threat
we should categorically refuse this
approach to trade which leads the
destruction of the environment
endogenous peoples and these countries
we should be trying to protect their
forests or our forests by adopting
sustainable approach dividing
guaranteeing the long-term survival
ecosystems
thank you very much president
the large
tropical and subtropical rainforests in
developing countries have ecosystems
which are essential for the world and
for Humanity they affect water cycles
they affect meteorology and biodiversity
so the degradation of our forests and
deforestation
have clear objective causes from Bad
Forest management or commercial
exploitation or large aggro businesses
the EU cannot avoid its responsibilities
when it comes to deforestation
its policies have endangered forests in
member states as well through free trade
agreements to try and dominate the
resources of third countries
the interests of multinational companies
are put ahead of those of the people
we need to safeguard participative
Community
models baldios in Portugal for example
having sustainable development without
deforestation and support small and
medium-sized production thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you president commissioner it is
important
to keep an eye on the origin and
production methods of products on our
markets for example products that have
contributed to large-scale Rainforest
deforestation
unfortunately despite the good
intentions I cannot support the
negotiation outcome here
first applying to regulation
retroactively since 2021 is questionable
and unfair from legal security
perspective
in addition well we already heard that
more than 75 percent of Finland is
Forest so every time when we build
something new we always need to cut a
tree or two
and well when we want to build something
bigger wind power Park
public buildings or New Roads for
example we need to cut even more trees
all this lead to deforestration but only
one country is put in an unfair position
and punished
and indeed our ministry for Agriculture
and Forestry has already asked cattle
Farmers to put their Investments on hold
as the consequences of this regulation
to cattle farming are so unclear
therefore
we need fairness and Clarity in the
implementation of this regulation to
secure future Investments they are
absolutely necessary to guarantee food
security and security of supply thank
you cut down into your acceptable card
do you accept it
yes madam
um
you asked for a blue cut
you asked for a question
yes uh
thank you president Elgin
you mentioned legal security and
retroactivity of this regulation and
also
the fact that cattle Farmers cannot
build single buildings on their Farms
but how do you see this
in in a larger scale do you feel that
this regulation should be implemented
also in Europe products so how would you
have done this otherwise
to protect our forests well thank you
for this question of course when we talk
about large-scale deforestation and I
mean Global deforestation and rainforest
I'm not talking about our country with
more than 75 percent of forest
I'm not focusing on Finland here I'd
like to focus on making sure that those
Products that come from elsewhere
outside of Europe they are controlled
and their trade is controlled and we
have to do something about it madam
thank you very much we come now to the
catch the eye procedure there are six
requests for the floor
is the first speaker
Mr Tomic
um
thank you very much I'd like to
thank the
rapporteurs this is a very important
instrument
we need to be strict not just within the
EU but also with those who want to have
access to our markets we need to protect
biodiversity and European consumers that
is why this regulation is so important
we need to have greater Clarity in our
legislation
so that we can protect not just our
forests
when it comes to deforestation
we need to provide
an extra opportunity to the economies of
these countries so that they can develop
in a way that respects legislation of
our Market Catarina
thank you very much for the floor Mr
chair none of us supports deforestation
the forests are lungs of the planet and
we all need to breathe we need to
support revitalization and reforestation
we also need to protect climatic
measures but not just by you know
senseless appointment of new parks we
need to support just and fair Forest
management and we need to think about
people whenever a new legislation is
approved for example whenever we approve
legislation on energy security of
buildings and we ban use of fossil fuels
we basically ban the use of gas heating
and people who are poorer and live in
these Village areas they need to solve
their heating situation and they end up
heating with wood also the current
situation to limit nuclear energy will
basically lead to lack of electricity
and people will end up burning wood
therefore we need to be very much
mindful that whenever we adopt
legislation we need to be very mindful
of every implication into our health and
especially people that will be affected
could buy it thank you
um
thank you very much
thank you president I think it's really
important that we have managed to reach
an agreement
on this text here before us and I really
appreciate the work done by our reporter
all those who have contributed to this
so I'm really welcoming the opportunity
to vote on this text it's a way for us
to support the fight against
deforestation this isn't just about the
deforestation
phenomenon in the EU we're talking about
countries outside of the EU they too
need to contribute we have rainforests
we have forests outside of the EU they
too need to be product protected and
products that come from those countries
will not be imported into the EU unless
they meet the requirements we've talked
about cattle we've talked about beef
we've talked about Rubber and so on and
so forth
and we know that these products have a
real impact on deforestation and we know
that they need to be therefore tackled
the floor is yours
may God please
it's going up yes oh wow it is it's on
hello okay now it works here
president
this regulation is a good example
on how good intentions and good purposes
and objectives can be spoiled in writing
the regulation text in an unclear manner
which can lead to consequences that
we've heard about today
for example one interpretation is that
if a cattle farmer builds a shed for his
animals the trees that are cut to build
a cattle shed
fall into the scope of this regulation
so it is very important to hear from
commission Representatives
how the interpretation should be done on
this regulation can it be like this like
I just described also forest fires they
produce
1.7 billion CO2
equivalence every year so that is a very
big share of
deforestation in the world
thank you very much
I'd like to thank the reporter who's
done an excellent job on this report
I was also cow reporter
on the opinion on forests
we have achieved a great deal this year
and I would like to praise the role of
the European Parliament we've managed to
reach agreement
on the conclusions
contained in this report and on those
Commodities which should not be imported
if they contribute to deforestation
however there are a couple of problems
first of all checks and oversights as
well as consumer protection
we know that if somebody drinks a coffee
or they should be able to know that they
are not contributed to deforestation
secondly how do we deal with our
worldwide partners
this is an important issue for the
United States
we should support all those countries
and presidents who don't want to allow
deforestation continue losing Sylvia and
others
open foreign
thank you very much our forests are the
lungs of our planet they are hugely
important so I agree that we shouldn't
be importing products into the EU
which have caused excessive
deforestation and damaged the planet and
the population
[Music]
when we look at the regulation it
affects our Farmers as well in my
country in Slovenia
uh I
have heard that organic farming is going
to become very difficult because
everything is being banned all of a
sudden
there are many different aspects that
are becoming problematic so
the people who are making these
proposals don't seem to have an
experience when it comes to agriculture
we obviously want to prohibit excessive
dehydration uh and import those types of
products though thank you
is the president honorable members so
thank you very much for your
interventions and your actions today
back in 2020 the European Parliament
called for regular reaction on the
demand size to address deforestation
a mere two and a half years later you
are now voting on a text and this speech
shows broad ambition and a widespread
sense of urgency
the new regulation may not reflect every
aspect of what you wanted to see but
this is the nature of a compromised text
and many of the key requests of the
parliament have been reflected and they
help improve the text and the result is
a truly ambitious piece of legislation
there is the potential here to make a
significant difference in our joint
fight against deforestation and Forest
degradation and the key will be the
effective implementation on the ground
and for that I do count on your positive
vote and for your continued engagement
thank you
thank you very much Madam commissioner
the final speaker for the debate is the
reporter Christoph Hansen
thank you very much president and thank
you to all of my colleagues who took the
floor in this debate today it's a strong
signal it shows that this topic is very
important and
as far as the objective is concerned we
are all across the board in agreement or
political parties so we have consensus
from that point of view we have six
groups that worked with us right to the
end and thank you for that it's a strong
signal like I said it shows that the
European Parliament is United on this
matter
I also noted today in the debate that
almost half of the speakers came from
Finland that's interesting in terms of
observations so maybe that is
something that we should take note of
and use it as an opportunity to clarify
things first of all there's no
retroactivity there is a date December
of 2020 we're not going to go back on
that back towards the past so let's be
clear about that particular issue this
instrument is it already perfect
probably not let's be honest let's
acknowledge that that's why there are
three review Clauses in this paper one
just after one year
it comes into effect in order to look at
the functioning of the system in terms
of its impact on the fight against
deforestation and then another two
review Clauses some further years down
the line in order to make sure that we
preserve any problems that are still
outstanding some which have been
mentioned now if a Finnish Minister were
to discourage Finnish Farmers from
making an investment right now I would
invite that minister to read the text
more closely you know I actually come
from a farming family I'm the brother of
a farmer a small holder 10 hectares no
more and now in Finland or in other
countries you know you need to take into
account the sizes of your Holdings you
know you're not going to make
investments every second year or every
fifth year in order to build for
instance a shed that is not uh opposite
if you only run a small holding so I
think that that too needs to be taken
into consideration we want to achieve a
fight against deforestation that is
effective here and around the world we
want it to work and together we can make
it work and therefore I would ask all
colleagues to please vote in favor of
this text which is a very good text it's
not perfect perfect might be in the
future but still please vote in favorite
[Applause]
thank you very much that closes that
debate and the vote will take place on
Wednesday
the next point is a joint debate on fit
for 55 we have uh Peter Lisa's report on
the emissions trading system
so we
have a number of different uh reports
here on a maritime